We have three main functions in trigonometry.
Three really important ones, which you will come across often.
They are sine, cosine and tangent.
Here's a fact, the names of all the functions in trigonometry
sounds scary.
If it's the first time you are studying trigonometry,
there is a very slim chance that you have heard
any of these names before.
We have learnt what functions are.
A function take some input
carries out a particular operation on it and gives us an output.
These three names
are just fancy names given to functions. Nothing else!
Let's assume, this is a sine function.
Say it takes in a random value theta.
It does some operation inside to give us some value.
What value? What operation ? That depends entirely on the triangle.
We know, that trigonometry generally deals with right triangles, like this one.
Let's assume this angle is theta.
The side opposite to the right angle is called the hypotenuse.
And the other two sides
are named with respect to the position of this angle.
As this side is right next to the angle,
it's called the adjacent side.
This side is called the opposite side
as it lies exactly opposite to our reference angle.
Please make sure you understand clearly
how the sides of the triangles are named.
This is the triangle we will be frequently referring to.
Adjacent is the side right next to the reference angle.
And opposite is the side opposite the reference angle.
Now we are ready to understand the sine function.
We will look at the sine of our reference angle.
The sine of angle theta, is written as sine theta.
Observe that we do not write the 'e'.
sine theta will always equal the opposite
which is this side divided by the hypotenuse.
Each of these sides will have a length.
So the sine of this angle gives us a numerical value.
Let's see an actual example.
We have this right triangle.
Let this angle be theta.
And let the lengths of the sides be three, four and five units.
The formula for sine theta is opposite by hypotenuse.
The length of the side opposite the angle theta is three units,
so we write a three in the numerator.
The hypotenuse is 5 units, so we write five in the denominator.
The sine of theta in this case is equal to 3 by 5 .
Which equals zero point six units.
That's how simple trigonometry is.
All we need to know is what the sides of the right triangle are called.